Tanna kind of style I guess I really do
not know now you know your life is
different now I was on Twitter and asked
you guys what kind of video you wanted
to see for today and a lot of you said
DIYs and a lot of you said under the
video about Valentine's Day gifts to
give or activities to do and so I kind
of combined all of that so today I'm
going to teach you it all you can make
some Valentine's Day gifts DIYs that are
loving thoughtful and also if you are an
irrationally jealous member of your
relationship there are gifts that you
can give as a jealous girlfriend to your
significant other and then gifts that
your significant other can give you as
jealous girlfriends so there's something
for everyone in this video enjoy our
first irrational jealousy driven DIY
bday gift is a standard DIY it's the
classic ironing a phrase or image on a
t-shirt this will be different for
everyone depending on their levels of
jealousy with their significant other so
create some sort of phrase or image that
you think really cuts your significant
other to the core and then print that
out following the instructions on your
specific transfer paper a lot of times
you'll have to mirror the image and make
sure you're printing on the flat non
line side but make sure you're reading
the directions on your specific paper
and the cut your image out however you
choose and slip it to the iron it image
side down on your selective piece of
fabric it can be a t-shirt it can be
boxers it can be some sort of large
child's leash whatever you want just
make sure again you're following the
transfer papers direction I want your
transfer paper head significantly cooled
you can peel it away to reveal ah your
totally irrational and jealousy filled
designs that your significant other has
to wear out in public otherwise they
don't love you for our next video you're
going to want to take a photo of
yourself looking down in some sort of
concerned way and then print it out
extra tiny from they're going to cut out
your photo and then tape it to the top
left or right corner of your significant
other phone that way whenever they check
any other breathing person social media
feeds or check any other breathing
person they know that you are always
watching whether you're there physically
or not our next DIY VJ gift idea can be
given from the jello significant other
or to the jello significant other I
found these really cute little glass
pendants that you can make into
necklaces and Mychal the cork top pops
off and you can stuff it for whatever
enough
that's what I say on any date that has
champagne ha ha you can use any kind of
nuts you want as long as they fit into
the black pendant today I'm using
caching all you're going to want to do
is take a couple nuts and place them
inside your glass pendant then you're
going to take a sharpie and write either
my nuts or your nuts on the outside of
the glass then use whatever going to
chain or string you want to take your
pendant and string it on to make a
necklace and we are you have your
significant others metaphorical nuts
around your neck it's a great gift for a
jealous significant other to give to
themselves in front of their significant
other so their significant other always
knows that they have your nuts around
their neck equally it's a great gift for
the significant other to give to their
irrationally jealous significant other
so that the Joe significant other knows
that you know that they have your nuts
around their neck either way it's
romantic and I'm healthy as [ __ ] this
next DJ DIY gift idea is for a
significant other to give to they're
extremely jealous significant other and
it's a classic all you're going to need
are the classic craft decorative
materials colorful paper some markers or
anything that's readily available
because you're going to make the classic
romantic coupons but the twist to this
DIY is this is not a coupon book for a
free massage or a night on the town or a
romantic dinner like a coupon book so
that you're jealous significant other
can have all of your social media
passwords because you know that one way
or another they're going to figure a map
the maple comes from New Romantic it
spot our life day away for any couples
with the foundation and their
relationship based on jealousy is Plan B
this doesn't have to be from any
particular person to another person the
couple should just have this on hand all
the time love bagels those are so really
really irrationally envious and just
kind of unhelpfully jealousy driven DIY
throughout hence a gift I hope that you
guys enjoyed it let me know which is
your favorite you like this video give
it a thumbs up and push this button
right here to subscribe to this YouTube
channel because I'm going to indirectly
validate your unhealthy behavior ah I
don't know
[Music]